Jacky's with us in North Carolina hi
Jackie
how are you Oh how are you sir better
than I deserve what's up my husband I
recently started the program and at work
they offer us these additional
insurances now a couple years back I was
diagnosed with cancer and I was left
with a really high deck so I I guess it
was a scare tactic and I signed up for
all these insurance policies additional
policy my question is should I still be
signed up for Allah just rely on regular
insurance a variety of my work what you
ought to do is kind of go back and visit
not the feeling but what really happened
when you got cancer that caused the debt
well I had I was self-employed I had my
own insurance policy but it didn't cover
everything okay my chemos you arranged
it went from 12,000 to 15,000 you know
it fluctuated and I was lost about
$250,000 with the death mmm okay so you
had a bad health insurance plan is what
you're saying exactly okay does your
current plan your current health
insurance plan with your current
employer is it a good one does it cover
the type of stuff that you experienced
before
yes okay so that need has gone away then
hasn't it yeah yeah and the rest of it
is gimmick okay
all the Supplemental policies are
gimmicks we recommend good health
insurance to cover cancer and heart
attacks and diabetes and anything else
that people run into its basic health
insurance needs you need good coverage
how much is your deductible hundred okay
five hundred dollars
yeah and what is the copay after that
twenty percent okay and so if you had a
100 thousand dollar bill from a hospital
you would owe twenty thousand
okay and two hundred thousand forty
thousand and so on okay that's a lot
different than where you used to be
agreed mm-hmm now of course you're gonna
if you're gonna work our plan you're
gonna get out of debt and then you're
gonna build an emergency fund of three
to six months of
expenses which would cover that copay
portion in 90% of the cases right yeah
and as you build wealth you'd have other
monies to cover anything above that if
you continue on and do our whole process
and follow through so I'm going to use
the money that's going to miscellaneous
cancer policies and short term
disabilities and all that kind of stuff
to make sure we have number-one debt
freedom and then number two build your
emergency fund and that combined with
good health insurance gives you the
coverage okay I don't own cancer
insurance I don't own short-term
disability insurance
I don't i have long term disability
insurance through our group plan here at
the office and i have a great health
insurance plan through our group plan
here at the office the company I own
okay
but I don't buy those supplementals I
self insure through my co-pays and my
deductibles with savings and I self
insure through any kind of income loss I
would have that's permanent with long
term disability short term disability
you would cover with your emergency fund
and that's the definition of a rainy day
so good question and it's got thing to
unpack and but the other stuff is
basically like you said it's fear-based
selling and it's gimmicky insurance and
you're much better off to spend your
money on other things
like sometimes fog thank you for calling
in sometimes folks are like at their
work have accidental death insurance and
it doesn't cost but $3
well that's $6 that's 72 dollars a year
and for 72 dollars a year how much term
insurance you could buy whether you
regardless of how you die whether it's
by accident or otherwise okay so here's
the thing you're not double dead if you
buy by accident and your family doesn't
need twice as much money they need the
same amount of money that's all and so
you don't need these gimmicky insurances